new Assassin's Creed details have leaked
plus The Last of Us Part 1 and Nintendo
switch sports are getting new features
so in yesterday's Gamespot news I
mentioned how the future of Assassin's
Creed would be revealed during an event
in September well it seems the franchise
couldn't wait because details have
surfaced about two games codenamed
project red and project Rift Kotaku
reported on Project Red's existence
while Bloomberg's Jason schreier said
project red is a part of AC Infinity as
opposed to a separate Game Source is
speaking to Kotaku said this game
whatever it may be could be set in Asia
reporter Jeff Grubb of sister site Giant
Bomb previously said it may be said in
Japan kotaku's own sources could not
confirm this but the site's insiders
said Japan as a setting for Assassin's
Creed has long been discussed internally
and that's no surprise as Ubisoft has
spoken openly over the years about how
Japan has been considered as a setting
for a future Assassin's Creed game but
project red and infinity aren't the only
new Assassin's Creed games in the works
at Ubisoft right now during an earnings
report call the company mentioned a
delay for another smaller premium
unannounced title reports now indicate
the game in question is Project Rift a
standalone AC game that was originally
meant to be DLC for Assassin's Creed
Valhalla according to Bloomberg News
Ubisoft bordeaux's office which is
leading development on the project
requested the game be pushed from its
targeted February launch due to the game
running far behind schedule the game is
now slated for release in May or June
according to the report which will move
it from ubisoft's 2023 fiscal calendar
now moving on to another game with
stealth elements The Last of Us Part One
naughty dog has revealed more details on
how the game has been remade for PS5 and
PC in a new deep dive video while the
core gameplay is essentially the same
players can expect graphical upgrades
new features and enhancements that make
the game more accessible some of the new
features outlined in the Playstation
blog post include a new permadeath mode
a speed run mode an updated photo mode
mode unlockable costumes for Joel and
Ellie and a model viewer mode on the
technical side The Last of Us Part 1 can
render in Native 4K at a targeted 30 FPS
or a dynamic 4K at a targeted 60 FPS
display mode the added power of the PS5
means that environments have denser
physics with tons of bumpables and
chipables that translate into gunfire
ripping concrete and other objects apart
more accurately with more than 60
accessibility options players can also
expect an audio description mode that
makes the title more easily playable The
Last of Us Part One will launch for PS5
on September 2nd but a PC release date
has yet to be announced now let's talk
about a game that will never come to PS5
or PC Nintendo switch Sports Nintendo
has announced that it will be adding
full motion control support for soccer
in switch Sports on July 26th this free
update is scheduled to go live at 6 PM
Pacific 9 pm Eastern and will include a
number of new features including the
ability for players to use the motion of
their legs to kick the soccer ball in
game when using the leg strap accessory
players will also be able to use their
hands while jogging in place to in-game
dash Nintendo explained that playing
this wave will translate users in-game
kicks to be more powerful and the update
doesn't just address leg strap players
it will also allow new moves in
volleyball such as Slide Attack and
Rocket serve aside from the motion
control support feature the game is also
adding new s-rank and infinity rank in
online pro league mode meanwhile I'm
over here just patiently waiting for the
promise golf mode to arrive and praying
hoping that it's followed up by a
surprise announcement of baseball making
its return
but until then I guess this update is
cool too let me know what sports you
want to make its way into Nintendo
switch Sports have a great weekend and
Tom we'll see you next week